For this video, I’m going to show you how
to make homemade microwave popcorn from scratch,
that’s delicious, healthy and ready to serve,
in a couple of minutes.
Start with a handful of popcorn kernels, like
the kind you find at the grocery store. You’ll
also need salt, olive oil, and a little sugar,
if you like it like that. And it’s also
a good idea to set a brown paper lunch bag
on the counter, because we’re going to need
it in just a second. Now for this recipe you’ll
need 1/3 cup of popcorn kernels, 1/2 teaspoon
of salt, and 1 teaspoon of olive oil. You
could also add 1 tablespoon of sugar and turn
it into a sweet and savory kettle corn. Now
pour the teaspoon of oil over the popcorn
kernels and let it soak down for a couple
of seconds, then plop them all into the brown
paper bag. The salt and sugar go in next,
and you can just pour them straight in over
top, then fold the bag over two
times to give it a little crease and hold
it all inside. Now set the bag on a paper
towel in the microwave for about 2:30
That’s the perfect timing
in my microwave, but every system is a little
different, so play around to see what works
best for you. When the popping slows to around
2-3 seconds between pops, it’s done. So
let it cool for a bit, then give it a quick
shake upside down to make sure everything’s
evenly seasoned. Just like that, you’ve
got in instant batch of kettle corn ready
to serve. Not only is this a fun and easy
way to make popcorn, but it’s about as fresh
as it gets, and doesn’t have any harmful
chemicals to worry about either either. Well
now you know how to make a tasty batch of
instant homemade kettle corn, or if you prefer
your popcorn salty, just leave out the sugar.
That’s it for now. If you like this
video, perhaps you’ll like some of my others.
Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com